We ask Japanese viewers: Do you
like junk food?
No, you don't, because no one has a
better taste than Japanese people.
Popular videos like these prove that fact.
First time in Japan I was
very impressed with my first Japanese food.Japanese food was so delicious that I couldn't help but cry.I'm
glad I came to Japan.I moved to Japan because of my long-awaited sushi experience.Japanese people don't
like junk food,
but for me, videos like this are the
best.  I think this proves that the Japanese people in the club are
addicted to junk food.I can
hear everyone's voices.It seems like the people in the video are actually
moved by it.Many of them are.
I was really impressed when I ate sushi for the first time.
Having lived in America, I know that
Japan's food culture is much more advanced than America. No, I
completely agree. As an American, I would like to acknowledge this.
I don't think so, but I
think Japanese people who eat rice, miso soup, side dishes, and pickles have really better tastes than Americans who eat high-carbohydrate foods on a regular basis.I think the Japanese people who eat rice, miso soup, side dishes, and pickles really have better tastes than Americans who usually eat high-carb foods.
The problem is that
these videos are not spreading the good things about Japan to the world.The
foreigners in the videos
may be experiencing Japanese culture for the first time, but that's just
one person.  There were at most a few people,
probably tourists, who were eating there even when the cameras weren't rolling.So
why do we go to the
trouble of recording them eating?
Who are these videos made for?
It's Japanese. Just look at the video's title thumbnail and
the comment section and you'll see that.
And there are always three exciting seasonings in a video like this:
oil,
salt, and sugar. There's so much about Japan, but
oil is Japanese.  I was saved by the kindness of people, but salt has
become a salt.I'm glad I came to Japan, but it
plays the role of sugar.And there
are various recipes using that seasoning.I cried
a lot when I tried the Japanese food I had always wanted.  The public safety is seriously
divine Half a day with caffeine I'm
jealous of the Japanese people who got the education I want to go back to Japan I've reached my limit in my own country which has a higher sugar content
For Japanese people who don't know anything about other countries, this is no matter
how much they eat.  It's a meal that makes you want to eat more,
and that's true.Humans want to
be praised.I also
check out the comments on my videos, saying that this expression
was interesting, or that
this is the first time I've seen a foreigner speak Japanese
so well.As expected of Dogen Channel.  I'm
glad I registered. This is delicious. I
could eat this forever. Please tell me more.
Unfortunately, this kind of food
has almost no nutrients. Dogen: That's
not a removal, it
's a withdrawal.
No, it's so bitter, I can't explain it well, but
Dogen is
like Larchion, it's unnatural. Don't do that. He's
teaching you an accent that's too sour. It's no good for Dogen to mess up his
public accent. It
seems like he can't swallow it. It contains
vitamins and dietary fiber that are necessary for growth.  That
's why when a
cheeseburger and
natto brown rice are
placed in front of us, everyone, including me,
reaches for the cheeseburger.What I would like to
say here is that we realized this and now we are
targeting Japanese people.  This
means that the number of companies that make large quantities of cheeseburgers, corn dogs, and cream donuts is increasing dramatically.The number of
foreign
YouTubers and domestic YouTubers who praise Japan
endlessly is increasing every day.  The question I want to
ask Japanese viewers is this: Do you think Mac and
Burger King
plan their menus with your health in mind, or do you
think they're thinking about the company's sales? Yes.
That's why we're dumping obscene amounts of
margarine and trans fat into our food.We're promoting the
goodness of Japan to the world.On
the contrary, we're forcing the
Japanese people to eat more and more cheap ingredients in order to increase their own profits.How
can we make Japan
cheaper?  There's a desperate competition to receive exaggerated praise.Recently, the
competition has become so fierce that
some people are talking about ordinary directions as if they were super moving events.It's
already become a genre.  You might
think it's better to bash Japan as a bad country, but you're wrong. I love Japan too. I've
lived in Japan for over 10 years, my
wife is Japanese, and my children
only have Japanese passports.  And
since I don't have any plans to go back to the US, I recently
built a house in Japan.Do you know?
That's right.I'm
making this video because I love Japan.I want to see my favorite friends
eating cheap food every day without knowing it.
As a foreigner, I want to say this to my friends who know that they still eat it.
Why don't you all change your eating habits a little? We've created a wonderful Japan by quitting this high-fat, high-carbohydrate,
prideful American diet.  Why
not return to a balanced Japanese diet with modesty and humility? I'm not saying you shouldn't eat sweets. What
I'm saying is that a
once-a-week
matcha daifuku is
more delicious than a daily Krispy Kreme.  I think it's good for both myself and
everyone else.Itadakimasu